this is the syllabus yeah the dopeboyz
and I will camp right now unsurprisingly
are the ones under es6
I wonder if you start to look through
these dot points how many of them just
look like a mess of words and really
like wait no I I recognize is down so
let me come back just look at the first
stop with you okay students should be
able to recognize that a sample can be
used to provide an essay for a
particular population characteristic
when the entire population can't be
assessed that makes sense doesn't it
right you can't access everyone was just
the Impractical to do so samples aren't
perfect but you can still use them as
estimates and have reasonable accuracy
with them right apply cutting techniques
this is the tricky one where we were
trying to work out okay sample beads and
all that kind of figured when you have a
sample of size list or a sample of size
that that's what we're looking at then
the sample beads I already mentioned we
talked about capture recapture why do we
capture to do this what's the point of
it so why is estimating population size
best achieved through capture recapture
why this technique
why not just say count them okay where
there's a population and you can't tell
them because they're moving around or
they're in a place where you just don't
have full comprehensive version that
bursts out to here so it says you guys
need to be able to generate random
numbers with a table calculator or
spreadsheet so you sort of you're
somewhere in the middle here I take that
everyone should have done this now the
if what a thing is and I don't a lot of
people mention this is we were just
setting up this feels weird
and it feels confusing as well can't we
just I get asked this question area can
we just make up some numbers they're
gonna be made up in here I'll just write
some numbers and then there we go does
it really matter where I got them from
the answer is yes it does really matter
tables are useful because they get you
out of your own brain I was mentioning
this to some people the front row just
now is a famous experiment where if you
take one person and they flip
50 times I can do this record heads
tails heads tails whatever it is and you
have them in one room in another room
you have someone who just imagine is the
imagines makes up a random set of heads
tails heads tails 450 times okay with a
great deal of certainty you can work out
which one was actually quotes the beef
and which one was making up the heads
and tails because humans are really bad
at thinking of random numbers when we
try to think of random numbers we
actually pick up things with quite a few
patterns example people who are thinking
of range of heads and tails so I'm gonna
steal second almost never in say a chain
of 50 will always never write down
something like this because if you're
trying to think of something random that
doesn't look random doesn't but the
thing is if you randomly flip a coin 50
times it's actually quite likely
eventually that you'll get 5 heads in a
row this happens in real life but human
beings we kind of gravitate away from
that because it doesn't feel as random
as something like this this looks like
it's more random to us so we kind of
trick ourselves with this that's my
tables are important calculators let's
have a look at this together so if
you've got your calculator there even if
you've actually got to this yesterday
I'm going to show you something which is
it included in the textbook but it's
actually kind of useful so to remind you
the key that you need is if you go shift
done that'll generate a random number
for you but it doesn't in a particular
way
so if you press equals if you press
equals it will give you a double between
0 and 1 and the more times you press
equals the more you get few doubles
right so you're equals equals equals
equals equals equals and this saw
generates a random numbers point okay
now we might want to say pick out of a
group of 24 students pick out a group
you know from 1 to 24 now this is not
from 1 to 24 so it's quite easy to work
out make a list of you know random
numbers out of 24 by just multiplying by
24 do you ever I said to you and just by
pressing equals you can see the numbers
will always be between 0 & 1
okay so therefore if I take these random
numbers and multiply them by 24 look
what happens you get a series of numbers
that is between 0 and 24 okay because I
multiplied my playful for example I
might get 0.999 and I multiply that much
2,400 be 23 point whatever and I drowned
that up and I'd say oh now I've got
person 24 something like that I haven't
done this for a little while so you're
gonna have to bear with me but what you
basically need I'm pretty sure is it's 6
okay I'm pretty sure that's it okay so
the question was asked what if I don't
want we'd decimal bits trailing off the
end you're calculating I can't do
rounding an approximation automatically
for you I'm sure there's more than one
way to do it but the way that I remember
is if you dig into the setup menu so I'm
going to clear
shift setup you can see six in there
says fix so you're going to fix the
number of decimal places that you want
and you can choose how many decimal
places you want so if you want holdup is
how many decimal places do you want zero
zero so if I hit zero then it's a zero
point and there are no decimal places
after that do you notice that so now if
I go back to 24 tons of random number it
will give me numbers between 0 and 24
are you happy with that sorry say again
[Music]
it gives you the right dose that is okay
now this technique I'm gonna buy little
bit undo the okay now this is an
important point I just want you to eyes
up for a second it's an important point
that the Dukes what kind of Colossus Oh
huh it's sort of bad as though because
it changes the answers that you get in
the process that you'll do so let me
show you one more time and I want you to
watch this time I'll get you to do this
when your attacker is in a bit but I
want you to watch it first you remember
I said to you if you don't muck about
with it you don't multiply it bringeth
you or anything like that it's going to
give you another between zero one how
many decimal places did you see it gave
you it gives you every time three now we
know the calculator can handle more than
three okay but it's giving you three
because it's just trying to it chooses
an arbitrary point basically okay now
the reason this is an issue is because
if you're trying to generate numbers
between 1 to 24 no problem okay I'm just
multiply that by 24 you get some numbers
out if you want to multiply sorry if you
want to get numbers between one and a
thousand this is also been a problem all
right because you've got three decimal
places and so when you multiply by
thousand
as you can see you're getting numbers
between one and a thousand as you'd
expect
watch carefully though what if I want
more than between 100,000 what if say I
wanted between one and two thousand this
is not a crazy idea because you know two
thousand students into school and I want
to pick something out at random I want
you to watch carefully what kinds of
numbers are there
just watch carefully then go through
slowly have a look look at all of these
numbers you know how wide range sure
enough they're between one and two
thousand does anyone notice anything in
common between all of the numbers so
every single number and you can now
verify this if you want go shift ought
to get rid of number multiplied by two
thousand because you know two thousand
scoot to the school every time you
equals you get an even number so in fact
you are not getting from one to two
thousand all of the odd people if they
are oddly numbered right I'm not going
to be selected that's not a random
sample is it you're leaving out part of
your population why is why is this
happening why is this emerging I'd like
to get more easy example changes to a
changes to ten thousand when you press
equals
do you notice it's a new problem not
only are there even they're all
multiples are why why are they all
voltage of 10
so how many decimal places where our
random numbers again how many got some
questions yeah with three right so for
example zero point five seven eight now
when you multiply this by a thousand you
get five hundred and seventy eight
that's fine and you might have got 0.577
that would become 577 so you'll get
every single number multiplied by a
thousand but the second you could over a
thousand there are only 1000 random
numbers with three decimal places
between zero what that's about
you can list them all out from here all
the way up to here
there's only $1000 okay so if you want
more than a thousand different random
numbers you can't do this you need to be
just a little bit sneaky up doesn't
require no pepper at the front there
instead of just a random number say by
10,000 I want you to put in tons of
random number okay now before you'd hit
equals unless you already have I want
you to think about what this will do if
you're now combining these two random
numbers you're going to get more decimal
places aren't you right so now were you
hitting yes you can see oh now we're
getting a whole mess of numbers now all
I'm doing at the moment is I just want
to point out this is one way of doing
things okay